There's always something coming and going
on Netflix with every new month, but May just
might be one of the best months yet.
From a whole bunch of new releases to the
return of fan favorites, here's everything
good coming to Netflix in May 2019.
The dark comedy Dead to Me stars Christina
Applegate as a grieving widow named Jen who
attends a support group and meets a woman
named Lucy, played by Bloodline's Linda Cardellini.
The two bond over their shared grief, become
friends, move in together...and everything
goes completely off the rails.
It turns out Lucy's kind of, maybe, totally
crazy, and now she's living in the same house
as Jen and her kids.
The trailer for Dead to Me teases a heartfelt
drama infused with the kind of humor that
could only come from having Will Ferrell and
Adam McKay as executive producers.
Tune in when the series arrives on May 3rd.
The title of this one says it all.
Extremely Wicked, Shockingly Evil and Vile
is about the trial and imprisonment of notorious
serial killer Ted Bundy, told through the
perspective of a single mother who dated Bundy
before his crimes came to light.
"I'm disguised as an attorney today."
Zac Efron stars as Bundy, with Lilly Collins
in the role of Elizabeth.
Extremely Wicked, Shockingly Evil and Vile
has all the makings of a dark, twisted descent
into the mind of a killer.
Take a look when it lands on May 3rd.
Flinch is an upcoming reality show that works
in the same vein as Fear Factor.
Contestants are put into gut-wrenching situations
and tasked with not flinching.
Whoever flinches the least wins.
What kind of stuff are they doing?
In the trailer, we see challenges as simple
as having a firecracker pop next to you or
a guy smashing cymbals right behind your head,
all the way up to seriously flinch-worthy
situations like being strapped to a chair
while a cement block on a rope swings inches
past your nose.
You can squeal in terror when the first season
swings in on May 3rd.
For its first three seasons, Lucifer was the
property of Fox, and Netflix added seasons
after they aired.
But now that Fox has dumped the series, Netflix
swooped in to grab the rights, and they produced
the upcoming fourth season.
Other than that, nothing much is going to
change.
It's still the story of Lucifer after he gets
bored with hell and moves to L.A. Hell 2.0,
if you will.
"Oh, it's times like this I wish I was still
in hell."
The fourth season of Lucifer arrives on May
8th, so keep your eyes peeled for that.
The Society centers on an affluent town in
which everybody except the teenagers mysteriously
vanishes.
It isn't long before they develop their own
rules for survival.
If you aren't with the cool crowd, you might
just end up six feet under.
It looks like a cross between Mean Girls and
The Purge, which is the kind of premise you
never thought you'd look forward to.
But now that it's here, well, we're pretty
pumped.
Tune in for Season 1 of The Society when it
drops on May 10th.
Wine Country follows a group of friends as
they head into the Napa Valley for a carefully
planned weekend of boozing to celebrate the
50th birthday of Abby, played by Amy Poehler.
But once all that wine starts stirring around
regrets and repressed emotions, the itinerary
goes out the window and this group of friends
takes a nosedive into a long, hard look at
their lives.
Fun!
Maya Rudolph, Jason Schwartzman, and Tina
Fey co-star, and Amy Poehler is directing.
Pour a glass and settle in when Wine Country
premieres on May 10th.
Even though it's ramping into its second season,
a lot of Netflix viewers have probably never
heard of White Gold.
The show centers on a team of salesmen in
a showroom in the '80s who think "business
ethics" is just a fancy phrase for making
as much money as possible, no matter what
it takes.
If you're looking for a new comedy series
to binge, be sure to check out White Gold
when the second season lands on May 17th.
The first season of the Danish thriller series
The Rain was praised by critics for its writing
and characters.
It's about a group of people banding together
to survive after a rain-borne plague wipes
out most of humanity.
The series centers on two siblings who leave
their bunker to find other survivors.
If you missed the first season of The Rain,
queue it up and get ready for the second season
to fall on May 17.
Spike Lee is producing this time travel joint,
which sees two high school kids on the cusp
of finishing a pair of time warping backpacks
when one of their brothers is shot by police.
They decide to use the backpacks to go back
in time and stop the incident from taking
place.
Of course, things go wrong pretty quickly,
and they find themselves in a loop of mistakes
that they desperately try to unravel.
Apparently, time travel isn't as easy as it
looks.
Jump in for the ride when See You Yesterday
shows up on May 17th.
Netflix's horror series Slasher brought in
solid reviews on its first outing thanks mostly
to its dedication to the genre.
Structured on the slasher movies of the '80s
and '90s, it manages to pay tribute to those
films while still bringing plenty of new stuff
to the table.
The newest installment, Solstice, isn't coming
with a lot of pre-release details.
All we know is that if it's anything like
the first two installments, we're 100 percent
in.
Take a look on May 23rd.
Netflix has been adding some pretty twisted
high concept horror lately with releases like
Velvet Buzzsaw and Await Further Instructions,
and continuing that trend in May is The Perfection.
Allison Williams of Get Out stars as a musical
prodigy who returns to her roots at her former
school, only to get an unexpected surprise
in the form of a younger student who appears
to be deeply disturbed.
There aren't many details available for the
rest of the plot, and most reviewers have
stressed how important it is to go into The
Perfection completely blind.
We're looking forward to doing just that when
The Perfection drops on May 24th.
How to Sell Hugs Online (Fast) is based on
a ridiculous true story about a teenager in
Germany who was trying to show his girlfriend
how cool he was, so he made a little business
selling drugs over the internet.
Before long, he was one of the top drug dealers
on the continent.
As the title suggests, How to Sell Hugs Online
(Fast) plays as sort of a dramatic guide to
everything this kid did.
You can find it on Netflix on May 31st.
Heart-wrenching and dramatic, When They See
Us is a limited series focused on the Central
Park Five, five teens who were falsely convicted
of assaulting a woman in New York's Central
Park in 1989.
After spending years in prison, their convictions
were overturned in 2002 in light of new evidence
confirming their innocence.
When They See Us will paint a dramatic portrait
of the young men's lives before and after
the crime, and the discrimination they faced
during the trial.
Look for it on May 31st.
Those are all the best Netflix originals coming
in May.
Now let's look at everything else.
Explosions, kung fu, and space dinosaurs fill
out the docket for May's action additions.
On May 1st, all three of the Matrix films
plug into the streaming service.
In the mood for more thoughtful fare?
Check out Snowpiercer, a 2013 post-apocalyptic
film starring Chris Evans as a lowly citizen
onboard a train carrying the last remnants
of humanity.
There's also going to be a wide range of thriller
and horror films landing on Netflix next month,
from movies like The Final Destination and
Scream to more low-key adventure thrillers
like The Da Vinci Code and its sequel, Angels
& Demons.
All of those selections arrive on the first
of the month.
Also on the first, look for dramas like Hoosiers,
Scarface, and Revolutionary Road, not to mention
the mind-bending cult classic Fear and Loathing
in Las Vegas.
Then, on the fourth, don't miss War Horse,
Steven Spielberg's 2011 World War I drama
that will turn you into a horse lover whether
you want to be one or not.
If you find yourself on the credits-end of
Revolutionary Road come May 1 and desperately
need a pick-me-up, you'll have plenty of options.
Netflix is doubling down on comedies next
month, bringing back raunchy genre favorites
like the first two Austin Powers films, Dumb
and Dumber, Harold & Kumar Escape from Guantanamo
Bay, and Wedding Crashers.
Look for those on the first.
Fans of CW superheroes rejoice!
Netflix is adding new seasons of the hottest
superhero shows throughout the month, promising
all the spandex and CGI you could ever want.
Arrow shows up on the 21st, The Flash on the
22nd, and Season 4 of both Supergirl and Legends
of Tomorrow on the 31st.
And if you've spent the last decade and a
half following the adventures of Sam and Dean
Winchester, you'll also be able to catch up
on Season 14 of Supernatural on the 3rd.
It's a little bittersweet, since fans know
the long-running show will finally be entering
the afterlife after its 15th season.
Other shows to look for include Colony: Season
3 on the 2nd, Pose: Season 1 on the 10th,
Riverdale: Season 3 on the 23rd, and the first
two seasons of Outlander on the 27th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Netflix stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.